Oprah invited five hundred of our
closest friends to our California home
over the weekend you must have a big
yard or a Gospel Brunch to celebrate her
new book it's called the wisdom of
Sunday's life-changing insights from
supersoul conversations it's a
collection of moments from the two-time
Emmy award-winning series super soul
Sunday what is the number one rule you
would offer someone to becoming their
most authentic self because this is
really what we're all looking for how do
I just be more of me I think it's it's
allowing yourself to be spontaneous
instead of responding to how you think
you're supposed to be we've all
developed an identity a sense of who we
think we are and who or not you defined
yourself how many but who you think you
are but who you're not on the show
that's Tony Robbins Oprah has in-depth
conversations with spiritual thinkers
including Tony Robbins who you just saw
that was sages wife sitting at service
age she explores inspirational topics
like forgiveness and personal
fulfillment we are pleased to have 60
minutes special contributor I love
saying that
Oprah sit up straighter right 60 names
yes good morning glad to be back at the
table
no we're glad to have you at the table
do you want to start with Bruce just to
say you were up late because you went to
go see Bruce well we were just talking
about it saw Bruce I'm seeing last night
and every time I think about it I'm
tearing up because it was the most
searingly beautiful performance I've
ever seen a person give he was so
engaged it was so raw so first year you
come away feeling more like a human
being one person show well yes it's
called Bruce and Jeff he doesn't want
you to sing which is very which is very
very hard what he was saying it's so
said I feel like my soul has been
stirred and now is once to rot I mean it
was wasn't that moving he'd be good for
a super soul Sunday be good for anything
but let's talk about your book the
wisdom of Sundays because I thought it
was interesting that you said without
Gary sook zhukov there probably wouldn't
be a super soul Sunday you
yes The Oprah Winfrey Show might not
have been on for 25 years because he
taught you about intention many years
ago I started doing these spiritual
conversations for which my producers are
all ago good we have to talk the
spirituality thing yes and Gary Zhukov
was on with his book seed of the soul
and my it was my intention to make that
book number one on the bestsellers list
so that it could become like the road
less traveled I watched the booksellers
list for years remembering the road less
traveled was now yes years so I wanted
to see the de Sol to become the next you
know offering and there was something he
said in that book about intention how we
all know that what you put out is coming
back but even before what you put out is
coming back there's an intention behind
what you put out so I use that principle
of intention actually for every one of
my shows since 1989 I would sit with the
producers and say when you present an
idea to me come clear and be clear about
what your intention is and I have to
find my intention within yours in order
to sit in the seat and to do the
interview so those principles of living
your life with a sense of integrity with
a sense of intention with essential
sense of gratitude learning to forgive
people for the mistakes that they've
made and you've made have really helped
me lead a more meaningful life so I've
interviewed all these thousands a
hundreds of people not thousands
hundreds of people feels like thousands
but hundreds of people and had my own
aha moments in the middle of it so this
don't you love when you have an aha mom
I just love when that I had a ha moment
moving reading this because you talk
about spirituality most people think of
a spirit like God yes yes yes that's the
spirit and you described to about
finding that that spirit is here yes not
outside because all of us are seeking
what I say is all of us are seeking the
same thing we share this desire to
fulfill the highest expression of truth
in ourselves and that's what
spirituality means to me it's the
essence of who you are you know I was
actually having a conversation years ago
with Carolyn mace who wrote a book
called anatomy of spirit and I could see
that the audience was dying on me you
know the people start doing this their
eyes are the lazy lazy over and I
stopped the show taping the show and
said do you
Hey in our tracking here and they said
we don't know what you mean by spirit
are you talking about cuz I think if the
Holy Spirit that's what they said are
you talking about Moses you talk about
the disciples what are you know I said
you know you have a mind you have a body
in your spirit so I think to nurture all
three which is what I really work at all
the time is is important and that's what
this book is all about and you know we
have podcast now not only podcast but 10
million people have downloaded those
pack I was gonna say I heard your
podcasts are doing well and I just love
your area that people are listening to
calming peaceful information that makes
their lives better on the way to work or
when they're working out in whatever can
we talk about this concept of disease to
please a little bit of what Tony Robbins
was talking about when I'm talking about
being spontaneous and not just trying to
act the way you think you're supposed to
act but the disease to please I got that
disease no more I don't have it anymore
but I had it for years that whole you
know the my biggest problem was learning
to say no and not saying yes when I
really meant no like yes yes so learning
to say no and learning that no is a
complete sentence and that doing you
know what change that was living from
the principle of intention so if you
only do what you intend to do then you
don't end up saying yes to things that
you don't want to say yes to yes that
zhukov book really changed you oh
majorly majorly so it was probably one
of the biggest influence this is for me
let's talk about what's happening with
Harvey Weinstein I know you posted on
Facebook already but you haven't kind of
spoken yet publicly about what's going
on I think that this is yeah I'm always
trying to look for the rainbow in the
cloud whatever is the silver lining and
this is what I do know for sure when
something this major happens when you
have the fallout 50 women coming forward
that it's a watershed moment and what I
do believe is actually happening is that
first of all it's triggering a lot of
unreleased pain repressed anger guilt
and suffering that a lot of women have
had I happen to be on set with several
actresses the other day and we were
filming some things and they were like
they were hadn't slept over a period
two or three days and I was like what is
that I said oh you guys are suffering
from PTSD and whenever be talking about
it out loud to everybody has a store
everybody has a story and so I think
this is a watershed moment and if we
make this just about Harvey Weinstein
then we will have lost this moment I
think this is a moment where no matter
what business you work in there have
been women who not only had the disease
to please that's a part of it
but who felt that in order to keep my
job in order to keep my position in
order to keep moving forward I've got a
smile I've got to look the other way I
got to pretend he didn't say that I got
to pretend he didn't touch me I think
those days are about to be over and if
it happens to you back in the day you
would say I'm sometimes you're not even
aware of what he just said was it really
inappropriate I know you've had a couple
moments where you think what did he just
yes I remember Gail had a moment when
she came and said to me would somebody
say no inappropriate I was like oh my
god you can see over that but no and all
I said was what did you say and then
they repeated it yes with my
twenty-something yeah if you pretend
it's okay but you know it isn't you're
right Jeff it absolutely absolutely but
a lot of women have been silenced and I
know I think it's gonna be being a
victim of child sexual abuse that when
you feel like you cannot be heard and
then other people start speaking out it
makes you feel like oh now I can speak
out too you've been speaking about it
for years could we just talk to you
about 60 minutes because I think it's so
interesting for you Oprah who's used to
being in control yes to be working with
a group of people that says that was
good what could you do that again well
let me just tell you how to go to 60
minutes so this is the process you know
the screenings interval I had two
screenings in one day because I have a
story coming up this Sunday by the way
so I had just waited and I decided I'm
just not gonna be nervous about
screening how many real good luck with
that I'm just not gonna be nervous about
you again but I love the processor I
love the process of sitting in a row and
everybody ripping your stuff apart
go back make it better
Jeff Fager has an ear and an eye like I
know I'm black nobody else nobody here's
the real deal and you even said you're
learning I'm learning things you know
you can reframe that you can take that
out and why did you use that word and
not that worried I just find it
fascinating I'm like yes sir okay sir
but but we're briefly tell what your
piece about because I think that you
could break news here today about my
piece no no not about your piece okay
2020 I'm wondering if you've narrowed
down your shortlist of VP candidates
she's lost her mind
no I have a minute to follow oh my god
Canada 2020 I was thinking of this show
people ask it all the time even I am now
starting to think the rules have changed
about running for president I said I
would bet my firstborn that you would
never do it in curvas hey well you can
you can be safe with that there will be
no running for office of any kind for me
but I thought you wanted to talk about
my 60 minutes piece
all right just briefly this is a good
question though I think that was a good
question clock is ticking as you know -
okay yes okay so thank God ago yeah John
Texas saying we gotta go the wisdom of
Sunday survival now it's really good and
you didn't watch Oprah's next 60 minutes
report Pelican Bay Sunday night right
here on CBS
thank you
watching CBS this morning